there were no limits to the jubilation
in dabshe to the complete surprise of
local residents a convoy of pickup
trucks had entered the town on Wednesday
morning and released dozens of kidnapped
schoolgirls many of them however are
still in shock we don't know why they
brought us back but they told us we're
Muslims and we share the same faith so
they didn't want us to suffer they
didn't molest us or subject us to any
kind of sexual harassment but they kept
one of the girls on religious grounds
she's a Christian and refused to
renounce her religion the parents of the
returned girls can hardly believe their
luck with some of them even fainting I
was crying a few days back but today I'm
laughing and feeling happy for the
release of our girls I saw with my own
eyes how the insurgents drove into town
this morning with the girls they were
waving their flag and telling people not
to run away as they were coming in peace
110 schoolgirls were kidnapped in dabshe
last month for weeks their desperate
parents receive no news of their fate
the government of President Muhammadu
Buhari has come under massive pressure
for its slow reaction to the kidnapping
and its failure to protect local schools